[Music]
and now from our eight news now i-team
from prescribed medication to illicit
drugs we're popping pills and leaving
traces behind and those traces are
ending up in lake mead prompting
scientists to sound the alarm the
i-team's david charns got an exclusive
look as researchers test our water for
drugs
why go out and test
our treated sewage i think it's
important because everything that we do
as a person or as a human actually
affects
everything around us we're all
interconnected for douglas sims that
connection's most pivotal point is right
here along the las vegas wash most of it
is processed sewage it's it's not dirty
it's actually really relatively clean
and safe
this is one of nine sampling sites
where dr sims and his team from the
college of southern nevada are pulling
out what we're putting in
we found a significant amount of drugs
drugs both legal and illegal flowing
through the wash and into lake mead thc
we found cocaine we found meth
sims research was part of a global
project testing more than 250 of the
world's waterways from antibiotics to
beta blockers caffeine to codeine the
pharmaceuticals our bodies are
processing are ending up back here
everything that people take and excrete
is coming through the system at you know
trace level but still present and able
to be detected quite easily with current
technology that multi-million dollar
technology bright inside this csn lab
those samples from the wash go through a
45 minute process where sensors and
software are plotting trace amounts of
those chemicals it's an anti-seizure
medication and we were there as the
results came in so does this mean that
the water going into the lake is
caffeinated oh yes it's going to be
small levels we're talking in parts per
trillion levels not yet harmful to us
while the water coming to our taps is
clean other organisms don't have the
privilege of a treatment facility mother
nature's machinery doesn't discriminate
i'm concerned this will be a bigger
problem later in the food web bacteria
is a very bad organism and if they get
exposed to antibiotics they get stronger
and stronger it will be harder to treat
them when you become ill with the
bacteria
over time as groundwater shrinks and the
amount of treated wastewater increases
those trace levels will only multiply
their effect on plants and small animals
living here the big unknown what will
happen in 20 years or 30 years to the
environment when we expose organisms
that we depend on we need them and if we
contaminate them with our drugs
that's going to come back to affect us
at some point simms and his team are
regularly collecting samples including
during big music festivals known for
hardcore partying and drug misuse over
those days he has recorded spikes in
drugs like meth and cocaine i'm david
charns live local now